bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de reporter sur
France 24 le 15 août 2021 les talibans
entraient dans Kaboul la capitale afghan
poussant les troupes américaines un
départ précipité les États-Unis mettent
en place rapidement des ponts aériens
pour faire sortir du pays ce qu'ils
appellent leurs alliés autrement dit le
personnel qui a travaillé de près ou de
loin avec les forces de l'OTAN et qui se
retrouvent donc menacés par les talibans
sauf que dans la précipitation ces
évacuations s'avèrent chaotiques
s'ajoutent à cela le fait que les
Américains ne veulent pas accueillir sur
leur territoire des Afghans sans
vérification de sécurité ils font donc
appel à des pays tiers et en tout ce
sont 27 pays qui serviront de terre
d'accueil à ses afghans en exil et c'est
en Albanie que nous emmène Nadia Pietri
Nadia vous avez co-réalisé ce reportage
avec Thierry Treluyer alors pourquoi
l'Albanie ce petit pays du Sud-Est de
l'Europe a été choisi comme terre
d'accueil pour ses afghans en exil
alors l'Albanie pour plusieurs raisons
mais d'abord parce que le pays a proposé
aux États-Unis assez rapidement après
l'évacuation de l'Afghanistan
d'accueillir les réfugiés afghans en
transit pour les États-Unis et dirhama
le Premier ministre albanais a
d'ailleurs assuré que les Albanais
étaient eux-mêmes il y a 30 ans
comparable à ces réfugiés à gants il
faut savoir par ailleurs que l'Albanie
est un pays très pro-américain qui a
toujours été soutenu par les États-Unis
et qu'accueillir des Afghans est aussi
pour Tirana une manière de s'attirer les
grâces de Washington on regarde votre
reportage on se retrouve tout de suite
après
Albanie terre d'accueil pour afghan en
exil c'est un reportage signé Nadia
bletry et Thierry trellier pour France
[Musique]
à 60 km de la capitale Albanaise
shenging et ses complexes hôteliers à
perte de vue
depuis l'été 2021 cette station
balnéaire héberge une clientèle
inattendue des Afghans qui comme la
jeune morsale on fuit leur pays quand
les talibans ont pris Kaboul
je viens d'Afghanistan et je suis dans
ce réseau
je suis là uniquement pour attendre
qui sont là
mon avenir est très incertain
en août 2021 les autorités américaines
épaulées par des ONG mettent en place un
pont aérien pour évacuer leur
collaborateurs afghan
3000 d'entre eux auxquels on a promis
l'Amérique atterrissent en fait en
Albanie
ce qu'on leur a caché c'est que leur
visa pour les États-Unis ou le Canada
n'allait pas de soi
chaque demande d'asile est étudiée au
cas par cas
et dans ce décor de carte postale un an
et demi après 1100 dossiers n'ont
toujours pas été traités
les Afghans livraient eux-mêmes ont des
vies en suspens
[Musique]
depuis presque un an moursal partage
deux chambres au RAFAELO Resort avec son
père et sa mère
pour protéger ses proches qui vivent
toujours en Afghanistan elle préfère ne
pas donner son nom son père un ancien
fonctionnaire lui ne veut pas être filmé
que je pouvais partir je leur ai dit ok
mais je ne veux pas
attendre ta famille
je leur ai dit oui évidemment ce sont
mes parents c'est vraiment fou et
absurde ça a séparé tellement de famille
morsal a travaillé avec des
organisations internationales à Kaboul
elle a obtenu facilement son visa pour
le Canada passer par an à 29 ans très
dévoué à sa famille elle est confrontée
à un dilemme insupportable
commencez seul une nouvelle vie au
Canada où y renoncer pour rester en
Albanie avec ses parents
âgés et malade
je me sens détruite à cause de ces
médicaments il ne reste plus rien de mon
corps
[Rires]
même si c'est une prison magnifique une
prison balnéaire où la liberté est
devenue un mirage surtout pour ceux qui
ont été directement exfiltrés
d'Afghanistan par des ONG américaines
pour eux pas de garantie de visa de la
part de Washington ni de soutien
financier
pour le département d'État les
organisations qui ont choisi d'évacuer
les Afghans vers l'Albanie en 2021
doivent en assumer seul la
responsabilité
pourtant toutes ne le font pas si l'on
en croit blédard Chima le gérant de
l'hôtel Raphaël
il y a une organisation responsable des
afgans qui n'a pas payé l'hôtel depuis
plusieurs mois
et ils sont toujours en tête aujourd'hui
ce groupe s'appelle FPG d'après notre
comptabilité il nous doivent un peu plus
de 2,8 millions de dollars
321 afghan prise en charge par le groupe
F PJ ont dû quitter le raphaëlo pour
être relogé mis octobre dans des
appartements moins coûteux nous avons
contacté l'organisation qui ne nous a
pas répondu
[Musique]
27 ans est l'un des bannis du Rafaello
il vit dans ce petit appartement avec sa
femme et son fils où la réinstaller
Fidji le fédéral practice groupe un
cabinet d'avocats de Washington fondé
par un ancien marine
mais pour Amir comme pour les autres
afghans qui ont quitté l'hôtel rien ne
va plus
à partir du jour où on nous a emmené ici
aucune promesse n'a été tenue
on nous a donné de l'argent pour nos
dépenses mais c'est n'importe quoi
imaginez 75 dollars par personne et par
mois c'est tellement peu
rien que mon petit garçon par exemple a
besoin d'une boîte de lait en poudre par
semaine si on multiplie les doses par 4
pour le moins ça revient déjà quasiment
à 80 euros
[Musique]
en Albanie depuis plus d'un an Amir
travaille de temps en temps dans cette
petite épicerie albanaise ou désormais
la plupart des clients sont afghans
ce n'est plus possible pour moi
maintenant de retourner dans l'hôtel
Raffaello alors je travaille ici avec
Chacha à l'épicier et ça m'aide beaucoup
[Musique]
ce jour là des familles prises en charge
comme Amir par Fidji sont venus
récupérer l'aide financière promise pour
le mois
mais une fois de plus il constate que la
somme ne leur permettra même pas de
survivre dans ce bout du monde albanais
le ton monte
les exilés afghans redoutent de
critiquer à visage découvert une
organisation dont il dépendent tant
qu'ils n'ont pas obtenu de visa pour les
États-Unis
à l'abri des regards cet homme accepte
pourtant de nous parler on a risqué nos
vies et la raison pour laquelle on est
là c'est parce qu'on a soutenu la
mission du gouvernement américain en
Afghanistan et même l'OTAN
si on nous traite comme ça
alors pourquoi les gens feraient
confiance aux États-Unis à l'avenir
si notre pays n'avait pas été donné au
taliban on n'aurait jamais été obligé de
le quitter
pour les résidences afghans du Rafaello
la situation est moins précaire trois
repas par jour et des indemnités
mensuelles pour certains réfugiés
boursal elle il y a même trouvé un
travail
bilingue elle enseigne l'anglais tous
les après-midi aux candidat au départ
les femmes sont les plus assidus
je suis très contente pour les femmes
qui ont pu sortir d'Afghanistan je sais
qu'il y a des millions de femmes qui
n'ont plus la possibilité d'aller à
l'école
et je suis heureuse que les femmes qui
sont là est accès à l'éducation qu'elle
mérite
aucune de ces femmes ne s'imaginait
vivre un jour en Albanie un pays dont
certaines
ignoraient même l'existence avant d'y
atterrir
mais pour ces jeunes joueuses de
football de l'équipe nationale féminine
quittait l'Afghanistan des talibans
était une question de survie
l'espoir nous aura cher ZI faire sortir
du pays les joueuses qui n'ont pas
réussi à partir
elle envoie une vidéo à l'une de ses
coéquipières qui se taire aujourd'hui en
Afghanistan
c'est très dur pour les filles qui sont
restées car la situation est horrible
là-bas
les filles ne peuvent pas aller à
l'école faire de sport elle reste à la
maison et elle ne se voit aucun avenir
elles disent même je ne sais pas si je
serai encore vivante demain
et la douleur de l'exil pour les
réfugiés afghane d'Albanie arrachés à
leur famille comme Zora Sher zai qui n'a
que 17 ans
mais nos familles sont loin et elle nous
manque tellement
ici certains ont réussi à venir avec
leurs proches pas nous et pour nous
toutes ces dures on est trop jeune pour
être séparés de nos familles qui souvent
sont dans des situations difficiles
ma mère est très malade et elle me
manque
à chaque fois qu'elle m'appelle avant de
raccrocher elle est triste et elle me
demande est-ce qu'un jour nous aussi on
pourra être réunis et avoir une vie
normale comme tout le monde ma fille
est-ce que je pourrais te revoir un jour
[Musique]
Amir passera probablement un nouvel
hiver en Albanie où son deuxième enfant
devrait naître dans quelques semaines
[Musique]
moursal elle a enfin reçu l'e-mail tant
espéré le Canada vient d'accorder un
visage ses parents la famille devrait
pouvoir s'y envoler dans quelques jours
au téléphone morsal nous confie ses
espoirs
[Musique]
quand j'ai lu cet email je me suis
sentie heureuse mais vide aussi
j'espère que ça ne va pas être le début
d'une nouvelle prison j'espère que je
trouverai un lieu que je pourrais
appeler ma maison
c'est ça mon espoir
comme morsal les réfugiés afghans
Albanie rêvent tous d'un avenir meilleur
et de pouvoir quitter enfin leur vie
d'incertitude loin du chaos de
l'Afghanistan
voilà pour ce reportage Nadia on vous
retrouve on entend dans le reportage un
homme très critique vis-à-vis de l'OTAN
vis-à-vis des États-Unis est-ce que
c'est un sentiment que vous avez pu
constater de manière plus générale parmi
les Afghans que vous avez rencontré
et en tout cas une incompréhension
certaine et une désillusion très marquée
pour beaucoup en particulier pour une
génération qui a grandi avec l'OTAN et
qui a vu tous ces espoirs anéantis avec
le départ de la de la coalition
d'Afghanistan comme vous allez
l'entendre d'ailleurs dans l'interview
de cet ancien traducteur qui a travaillé
pendant 7 ans pour l'armée américaine
du jour au lendemain tout le monde a
quitté l'Afghanistan
et moi je leur demande juste de prêter
plus d'attention au peuple after
particulièrement aux femmes et aux
enfants qui subissent beaucoup de
menaces et non plus de vie en fait ils
ne font que souffrir souffrir de tout
même ma famille vous savez ma famille
aussi parce que comme j'ai travaillé
pour les États-Unis il reçoivent des
menaces quotidiennes
les gens n'en reviennent pas vous savez
que tous ces pays la communauté
internationale qui nous ont abandonné
comme ça c'est incroyable
en novembre vous êtes resté en contact
avec certaines personnes que vous avez
rencontrées sur place quel est la
situation aujourd'hui à l'endroit où
vous avez filmé ce reporter
alors beaucoup de réfugiés afghansing
comme morsal et Amir que vous avez vu
dans le reportage ont pu rejoindre leur
destination finale moursal est
aujourd'hui au Canada et Amir lui est en
Virginie aux États-Unis mais d'autres
n'ont toujours pas réussi à obtenir de
papier c'est le cas notamment de
choucria la jeune musicienne qu'on voit
au début à la fin du reportage et elle
disait qu'il y avait environ 300 à 400
personnes comme elle sans document de
voyage dans l'hôtel Raffaello il y en
aurait d'après elle également 300 à
l'extérieur dans la ville de change in
donc en fait comme nous disait le
département d'État américain c'est
visanes ont rien d'automatique ce qui
veut dire que pour ces afghans coincés
en Albanie la vie est toujours en
suspens deux ans après l'évacuation
l'évacuation d'Afghanistan merci
beaucoup Nadia c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui merci à vous de nous avoir
suivi vous pouvez retrouver l'ensemble
des grands reportages de la rédaction
sur le site internet france 24 com à
bientôt